vamos a practicar la suma de números que
contengan centésimos pause en este vídeo
y traten de sumar estos dos números a
ver qué resultado obtienen
muy bien ahora vamos a resolverlo juntos
hay muchas maneras de sumar decimales y
aprenderán maneras más rápidas y
sistemáticas de hacerlo en el futuro
pero yo les enseñaré algunas maneras en
que mi cerebro lo resuelve una forma de
pensar en esto es decir que estos son 53
centésimos o también lo pueden leer como
5 décimos y 3 centésimos o 53 centésimos
y le vamos a sumar 42 centésimas
y si tenemos 53 de alguna cosa y le
sumamos 42 de esa misma cosa cuál va a
ser el resultado bueno cuánto es 53 42
en mi cabeza yo digo 50 más 40 es 93 más
25 así que esto es igual a noventa y
cinco centésimos
y si quiero escribirlo como un número
con punto lo escribo como 0.95 que se
puede leer como noventa y cinco
centésimos o nueve décimos y cinco
centésimos
ahora la otra forma en que podemos
pensar en esto es descomponer estos
números y decimos que este primer número
es cinco décimos más tres centésimos y
este otro número lo podemos reescribir
como cuatro décimos más dos centésimas y
luego podemos sumar por separado los
décimos y los centésimos así que si
tenemos cinco décimos más cuatro decimos
cinco décimos más cuatro décimos y luego
por separado sumamos tres centésimas más
dos centésimas más tres centésimas más
dos centésimos cuál es el resultado
bueno cinco décimos más cuatro décimos
es igual a nueve décimos y luego tres
centésimas más docentes imos es igual a
cinco centésimos que lo escribimos como
0.05 y luego nueve décimos más cinco
centésimos va a ser igual a punto 95 que
también podemos leer como noventa y
cinco centésimos
vamos a hacer otro ejemplo
digamos que queremos sumar 68 centésimos
más 33 centésimas cuál va a ser el
resultado y como siempre pausa en el
vídeo y tratan de resolverlo hay un par
de maneras en que podemos pensar en esto
una es que podemos separar los décimos y
los centésimos hagámoslo de esa forma
podemos reescribir este primer número
como seis décimos más 8 centésimos y el
segundo número lo podemos reescribir
como tres décimos más 3 centésimos
y si sumó los seis décimos y los tres
décimos dejen de hacerlo voy a escribir
aquí todos los pasos pueden hacer la
mente o escribirlo en un papel
ustedes no necesariamente tienen que
escribir todos los pasos entonces estos
son los décimos y por separado voy a
sumarlos centésimos + 8 centésimos + 3
en décimos entonces seis décimos más
tres décimos esto es lo que hemos hecho
en vídeos anteriores esto es bastante
sencillo pero si quieren podrían revisar
esos vídeos anteriores esta es igual a
nueve décimos
si tengo seis de alguna cosa y le sumo
tres en este caso estamos hablando de
décimos el resultado va a ser nueve
décimos
y esto lo podemos ver como 8 centésimos
+ 3 centésimos
si tenemos 8 de alguna cosa y 3 de esa
misma cosa obtendremos 11 en este caso
11 centésimos como escribimos 11
centésimas como un número decimal bueno
una manera de hacerlo es 0.11 o podemos
leerlo como 11 centésimos o también lo
podemos ver como 10 centésimos
más un centésimo
y 10 centésimos es igual a un décimo así
que podemos ver esto como un décimo
un décimo y un centésimo y cuando lo
sumamos todo nueve décimos más un décimo
más un centésimo esto se vuelve muy
interesante voy a reescribir lo aquí
nueve décimos más un décimo más un
centésimo cuál va a ser el resultado
nueve décimos más un décimo va a ser
igual a diez decimos que es lo mismo que
un entero todo esto es igual a uno más
un centésimo uno y un centésimo y lo
resolvimos
como lo he mencionado en vídeos futuros
vamos a aprender formas más rápidas de
hacer esto son formas en las que podrán
resolver esto automáticamente pero lo
que es realmente importante es que
piensen en lo que estamos haciendo aquí
ok dónde centésimos es lo mismo que un
décimo más un centésimo y estoy tomando
este décimo y lo estoy sumando a los
otros nueve décimos que teníamos de este
lado y vemos que esto es un entero en el
futuro vamos a ver cosas cómo llevar
decimales pero en esencia esto es lo que
está sucediendo conceptualmente y es muy
importante tener una idea de todo esto
antes de aprender métodos más rápidos